hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well Alistair McIntyre is going to
finish his essay how to seem virtuous
without actually being so by looking at
what he calls the inadequacy of and he
puts this in quotes a shared public
morality now why is he headed there at
the conclusion of this very interesting
analysis that he's carrying out well he
he made the case earlier that we don't
really have a shared public morality in
any real sense because a shared public
morality would actually involves some
sort of real account a systematic and
coherent account of the virtues as well
as many other things as well so moral
education is going to be inherently both
hindered and problematic within the
situation that that we're in and instead
of having a shared public morality what
we really have he says is a shared moral
rhetoric so a rhetoric is a way of using
language to attempt to convince other
people of your point of view get them to
do things it's not the same thing as
actually educating building people who
could be in fact virtuous and really
what this is is a
superficial sort of uh let's let's call
it
vocabulary that people use that has a
lot of you know warm associations with
with
virtues and uh you know the opposite uh
painful prickly
associations with what we call vices and
and we don't always have to use the
language of virtue we can just talk
about the virtues and say you know that
person is courageous that person is
cowardly that person has Integrity that
person's a sellout we have all sorts of
words that we use but the trouble is do
we have any real agreement about what
those words even mean and you know a lot
of people sort of assume that because we
have a single word we're all in
agreement about it and McIntyre says H
that's not the case and if you want a a
more fully developed case for this check
out his work after virtue that talks
about this in great detail and at much
greater length so in the the section the
inadequacy of a shared public morality
he says that the morality of the virtues
presupposed by and advanced in such a
rhetoric is not
determinant in the way and to the degree
that to use two examples the
Aristotelian or the humean or other
rival and controversial standpoints are
and then he says well how could it be it
can't be determined now that's a term
that he's using here determinate and
indeterminate to determine means to be
able to specify to particularize to go
into greater depth and detail about
something in this case what a virtue is
and what it requires and so he says how
could it be well it represents so far as
possible what is generally acceptable
what the adherence of every standpoint
and none are able to agree in asserting
so what would be an example of that he
doesn't provide one right there but we
can think of the virtues that he's going
to bring up in his cases courage who's
against courage everybody thinks courage
or bravery or whatever you want to call
it is a good thing but what is actually
courage oo now you know when we go
beyond what's generally acceptable A
what he's going to call in just a moment
a shared minimum gets very fuzzy it gets
indeterminate if you ask an Aristotelian
well what is courage they can tell you
about it and they can give you all sorts
of examples some of which are drawn from
Aristotle some of which represent you
know further thought on the matter by
people who identify themselves as
aristotelians you can do this with David
Hume even though his ideas are a little
less distinct you can do this with the
stoics who have great analyses of it you
could even do it with the utilitarian
tradition as as uh McIntyre is going to
point
out so this this you know shared minimum
he says this shared minimum is just what
the political order as such should
uphold and require no less but also no
more so as soon as you start getting
beyond that things start getting
controversial I also do want to say
something that goes a little bit beyond
what McIntyre is saying here because
this is a uh piece that he is writing
several decades ago and you know we do
see quite a few people for example in
American culture who are attempting to
impose a shared public morality largely
drawn from uh you know right-wing
sources conservative sources and what we
see with them is that they don't have
any better idea about the virtues than
the rest of us do because most of the
time they La certain things like courage
or integrity and then they don't show it
at all it's not courage to allow your
party to coers you into voting for
things that you know are actually wrong
and and evil it's not um uh Integrity to
make all sorts of claims about you know
uh sexual practices and then turn out to
be uh either a a you know child molester
yourself or somebody who covers that up
so what we see is that even when there
can be a robustly
articulated attempted shared public
morality oftentimes it's it's not it's
it's uh it's kind of a counterfeit to
use McIntyre's terms so um why does this
shared public morality this minimum why
does it fail us McIntyre says that it
fails us because of its
indeterminateness it doesn't tell us
what we need to know and so he says um
it fails us just at those points at
which the political social and cultural
order most needs what only the virtues
can supply and when he's saying only the
virtues can supply he means people who
have the virtues and actually understand
from some robust systematic coherent
account what a virtue actually is and
what it demands of us now why would that
be the case so he says that the success
or failure of any system of the virtues
is largely a matter of how successful or
otherwise those educated by it and in it
are in doing something really important
in
extrapolating in their practice as well
as in their Theory from those situations
in which they first learn not only what
Justice courage generosity and the rest
require but actually to act as Justice
courage generosity and the and the rest
required in the right way at the right
time to the right degree this is very
Arista tilian of course to other new and
relatively unfamiliar types of
situations so uh you learn what Justice
is by your interactions with people in
the workplace now you actually get a
house and you're living in a
neighborhood and you're thinking about
cases where you have to deal with
neighbors who perhaps are being you know
unfair to you how should you behave
nobody actually told you that this is
what Justice look looks like in this
circumstance but if you've actually
developed the virtue of Justice in a
real way not a counterfit way then you
should be able to transfer it from
situation to situation right and this is
what's lacking to this supposed shared
public
morality so he goes on and he says that
the weaknesses of the shared morality of
commonplace usage this rhetoric
essentially arise from from the
conjunction of the fact that
indeterminateness in respect of
extrapolation leaves its adherence
without adequate instruction just at
this point and of the fact that it's
just in these new and relatively
unfamiliar situations from the
standpoint of the maxims that embody
commonplace usage concerning the virtues
that a crucial need for the virtues is
most evidence so there's an interesting
Paradox here without a substantive
account of the virtues you don't have
have what's needed in order to morally
educate people in a substantive account
of the virtues and instead you give them
this kind of cotton candy fluff of a
moral vocabulary or rhetoric without any
adequate guidance and this is how we get
all sorts of people
posturing as you know endorsing virtues
but when the proverbial rubber hits the
road they're at a loss they don't know
what to do or what to ADV I other people
to do and McIntyre is going to give us
three example situations um the first
one involves courage versus honesty the
second one temperateness versus Justice
the third one is a little bit more
complicated it involves intellectual
virtues versus integrity and honesty now
why is it a a versus in each of these
cases well because that's the stuff
where we really get into sticky
situations where we want to have
adequate guidance or the capacity to
rightly figure this stuff out for
ourselves these are the sort of
situations in which this transfer from
where we're comfortable what we've
learned to new situations comes up so
the first one he says uh concerns a
marine officer who has learned how to
act in accordance with what these two
virtues courage and honesty require in
highly specific types of situations so
courage to the point of self-sacrifice
in the face of harms and dangers pose to
the security of his or her country by
some external enemy great they've
learned what courage is in that respect
they've also learned to be honest both
in dealings with fellow officers and
reporting to his or her superiors okay
so courageous honest Marine now they're
in a new situation what's the new
situation so suppose that at some later
time he or she is ordered by those
superiors for the sake of some cause
Inseparable from the security of his or
her country to organize and undertake
some clandestine scheme clandestine
because it must remain unknown to the
country's enemies but now suppose that
in order to achieve those
ends they have to deser deceive not only
those enemies but the political
authorities to whom in The Last Resort
he or she and his or her superiors are
accountable and the public to whom in
turn those authorities are
accountable how do you reconcile what
courage and honesty require in a new
situation like that what McIntyre says
is um I'm not going to actually try to
discuss this but the point that matters
for my argument is that a too
indeterminate conception of the virtues
of courage and honesty leaves such an
officer morally resourceless this is a
term that McIntyre uses a lot
resourceless meaning that you don't have
what you need in order to figure these
things out well right too indeterminate
a conception is just what the morality
of commonplace usage will supply it
won't give that officer the intellectual
and moral resources they need in order
to resolve this
situation what about the next one this
is more of a economic matter uh it
involves temperate temperateness and
Justice so he says imagine in this
instance someone engaged in commercial
activity who has learn the maxims of
commonplace usage in respect of
restraining intemperate Desires in
everyday life and giving to each what is
properly his or hers so it looks like
they've acquired Temperance uh
temperateness and just jce or Temperance
right and he says okay imagine that this
person discovers by taking a quite new
kind of risk with now notice this
qualifier legitimately borrowed money
not stealing it right he or she has a
reasonable expectation of making sums of
money in extraordinary excess of what
has hitherto been possible but the
lenders never envisaged this kind of
risk and the consequences for the
economy are
incalculable and McIntyre says okay how
do you enact temperateness and Justice
in a situation like that as the person
who is tempted to engage in this new
kind of risk-taking with other people's
money money that they didn't sign on to
being used in that way is that unjust
what does Justice call for what does
restraint of one's uh Desires in this
case for making tons and tons of money
but taking on a lot of risk what does
that require again McIntyre doesn't
provide you with a solution he just
tells you that once again this person
with two indeterminate a conception of
temperateness and Justice morally
resourceless they do not have what they
need in order to adequately uh figure
out how to reconcile these these virtues
or the virtues require third one very
interesting a scientific sort of context
a scientific researcher who knows that
he or she can only hope to obtain
further funding for a very important
research project if he or she can
produce some positive findings now but
it is in fact a good deal too soon for
it to be possible to produce such
findings the researcher thus faces the
following
dilemma either falsify the reports of
the data so far or imperil the entire
project they've learned to Value the
goods that are to be achieved through
the exercise of the intellectual virtues
and scientific inquiry and those of the
virtues of integrity and honesty but how
do they now decide between these which
which should they favor what should they
do again the indeterminateness of the
conception of the virtues as understood
in terms of the commonplace usage
precludes the possession of such a
capacity and those whose moral education
was limited to those conceptions I mean
part of what he's saying here is why
basic ethics training doesn't really
help out much because you know as a
researcher you're you're told oh you
must never falsify findings well why not
oh it's just bad you know there's a rule
against it uh it could lead to you know
in know utilitarian white bad effects
throughout the system there's never any
real explanation of how this ties in
with the intellectual virtues as
understood in a a classic virtue ethic
sense so he goes on and he says these
three examples um you know I I'm not
worried about the question of what ought
to be done or left undone but on
something more important the lack of
resources afforded by what we call
shared public morality of commonplace
usage it doesn't give people what they
actually need and so he says if you're
going to try to base a sort of common or
public moral education just on
this it's going to have bad effects it's
not going to give people what they
actually need in order to as we could
say do ethics and understand ethics well
and so he concludes by saying what the
morality of the virtues articulated in
and defended by the moral rhetoric of
our political culture provides is as it
turns out not an education in the
virtues but rather and here we get to
the title an education in how to seem
virtuous without actually being
so
that